subcommittee will come to order
on March 29 1933 President Roosevelt
sent a very important message to the
Congress I quote there is an obligation
upon us to insist that every issue of
new security shall be sold in interstate
commerce shall be accompanied by full
publicity and information that no
essentially important element attending
the issue shall be concealed from the
buying public this proposal adds to the
ancient rule of caveat emptor the
further doctrine but the seller also
beware it puts the burden of telling the
whole truth upon the seller it should
give impetus to honest dealing in
securities and thereby bring back public
confidence this committee and the
Congress responded by passing the
Securities Act of 1933 and the following
year again responded by passing the
Securities Exchange Act of 1934 both of
these statutes and the subsequent
federal security laws were passed by the
Committee on interstate and foreign
commerce the former name of this present
committee the Committee on Energy and
Commerce pursuant to rule 10 of the
rules of the house the Committee on
Energy and Commerce is responsible and I
quote for all bills resolutions and
other matters close quote
relating to and I quote again securities
and exchanges that same rule requires
the Energy and Commerce Committee to
review and study on a continuing basis
the application administration execution
and effectiveness of the laws which are
within the jurisdiction of the committee
pursuant to that requirement of the
rules of the house on December 11 1986
the Subcommittee on Oversight
Investigations instituted its current
round of investigative hearings at the
first hearing the subcommittee examined
the effectiveness of the market
surveillance and enforcement systems in
the light of the then recently
discovered insider trading scandals the
hearing has been followed by hearings in
19
87 in which the subcommittee looked at
insider trading the subcommittee also
examined the issues of mergers and
acquisitions and how investment banking
houses can and have put companies into
play this subcommittee has worked
closely with the legislative
subcommittee chaired by our dear friend
and colleague mr. Markey currently
dealing with legislation aimed at
reforming the securities market material
developed during the course of this
subcommittee's investigation has been
made available to improve the
legislation being considered and
legislation now being drafted by the
chair by and by other members of the
committee the subcommittee has been
concerned
throughout its enquiries about the
openness and the fairness of the
securities markets as the Second Circuit
Court observed in the case of Charles
Hughes & Company versus SEC and I quote
the essential objective of the
securities legislation is to protect
those who do not know market conditions
from the overreaching --zz of those who
do the question of fairness and
protection of investors will be the
subject of hearings today and tomorrow
these hearings will continue a
succession of hearings in which this
subcommittee and the committee has long
been engaged dealing with matters
relative to the securities market and
even relative to the stability and the
good health of those markets as well as
the concerns of investors the chair will
parenthetically observe that our
hearings today and tomorrow are based
upon thousands of pages of documents
voluntarily supplied by Drexel Burnham
Lambert the subcommittee has issued no
subpoenas to Drexel these Drexel
documents delivered without any
assertion of any constitutional or other
privilege speak far more eloquently than
anything else with regard to the role of
Drexel in the marketing of junk bonds
and indeed more so than any analysis
that our subcommittee or any member of
it could offer accordingly without
objection certain of these documents
will be included in the record at this
time
one issue that has been raised as a
result of the hearing of the
subcommittee held in October 1987 was
the use of high-yield debt to finance
hostile takeovers high-yield bonds or as
they are more commonly known junk bonds
have played a significant role in the
change in corporate America these bonds
are important to the American economy
they are one of the primary ways in
which new small companies obtain growth
capital and as such they confer great
benefit upon the American economies
these companies provide more than half
of the jobs created every year the
capital raised by junk bonds develops a
great share of the new goods and
services which make the cap of the
economy innovative and competitive in
the future inefficiency and diversion of
funds in this market are of serious
concern to the subcommittee of the
nation however companies which have
existed for decades which have carried
the brunt of our national defense
through two world wars which would
provide employment in the Heartland
America no longer exists they have been
victims of takeovers financed through
the junk bond market research and
development budgets have suffered as
millions of dollars have been diverted
to pay high interest rates on junk bonds
in short the competitiveness of the
United States in the international
market indeed our balance of trade and
the future of this country is impacted
by junk bonds in 1986 according to a
recently released report by the General
Accounting Office more than thirty two
billion dollars in junk bonds were
issued of that total approximately 40
percent were supposedly handled by the
investment banking firm of Drexel
Burnham Lambert the one individual most
knowledgeable of and most responsible
for the dominant role of that firm is
mr. Michael Milken the subcommittee has
hoped to obtain from mr. Milken an
understanding of how the market and junk
bonds originally developed and what the
role is for junk bonds now and in the
future and we hope that he will be able
to offer us some insights today the
subcommittee is concerned about the
liquidity of the market in junk bonds in
the event of an extended economic
downturn we know from our analysis of
public records that significant
quantities of junk
are currently held in the portfolio's of
a number of federally insured Savings
and Loan associations we have also
questions about the stability of these
investments we also know that a number
of insurance companies and mutual funds
have used and continue to use junk bonds
is an investment tool to prove to
improve their financial performance the
chair understands that there is a proper
role and a necessary role to be played
in the issuance of these below
investment-grade bonds at the same time
the committee is concerned that the
market remained liquid and the general
rules attending all securities issuances
be observed and that the rule announced
by President Roosevelt in 1933 still be
followed in other words let the seller
also be where the chair wants to
emphasize that the subcommittee's
proceedings today are neither civil nor
are they criminal the function of the
subcommittee today is to make a series
of enquiries the functions of the
subcommittee will be to see to it that
our responsibilities under the rules to
carry out oversight on matters under the
jurisdiction of this committee are fully
and properly carried out and that they
are carried out in a fair and proper way
the chair will observe that these are
not criminal proceedings although the
constitutional rights of persons
appearing before the committee will be
very very carefully protected the chair
also wishes to observe that the
proceedings today are not civil legal
proceedings in the judicial sense and
that although there again the rights of
all parties will be fully protected the
proceedings are the proceedings of a
congressional committee acting pursuant
to the rules of the House of
Representatives and will entail that not
only the burdens of the committee to
honor the rules and the constitutional
rights of all persons appearing before
us are properly attended to but also the
persons appearing before this committee
provide the necessary assistance to
committees within the framework of their
constitutional rights and the
limitations on the powers of the
committee the committee will observe
these rules established in the rules of
the house and the different statutes as
well as the constitutional with the
Constitution with great care the chair
will exist of course that all persons
appearing before this subcommittee will
observe them with equal care and equal
vigor chair recognizes the gentleman
from Virginia mr. blithely
the hearing today in the hearing
scheduled for tomorrow for the purpose
of examining possible irregularities in
trading of high-yield bonds specifically
with respect to transactions between an
underwriter and affiliates of the
underwriter we are making this
examination through a study of three
particular cases involving the firm of
Drexel Burnham Lambert the high-yield
bond market has exploded in the last few
years as these securities have been
increasingly used for a variety of
corporate purposes our objectives in the
hearings is not to debate the value of
high-yield bonds generally their
economic importance is in my view
indisputable the purpose of this hearing
is to determine to what extent existing
securities laws and regulations apply to
the transactions we are examining today
and what if any additional legislation
may be necessary at the appropriate time
we intend to ask direct questions about
some of the transactions in the three
cases presented we will attempt to find
out why these transactions occurred and
what the explanations are for them
although some may believe the fact
patterns suggest problems I am not
prepared to draw conclusions before
hearing all the facts and explanations
we are considering important issues what
I am concerned about the way in which
these issues are being presented I am
concerned that popular perceptions are
being created here that tend to lead us
to prejudge the issues for example
calling the employee accounts that we
are looking at inside our account
in flames the rhetoric wasn't but does
not assist us in our analysis of the
issues and everyone should realize that
this term is not widely used to describe
this type of account as far as I can
tell this term was used in the 1959 SEC
release and a 1966 court case I believe
that this type of rhetoric is being used
here to create a preconception let's not
make conclusions by semantics let's
carefully examine the facts in the legal
and policy issues we know from our
investigation thus far that there are
conflicting views on whether in how
relevant law applies to the type of
transactions we are looking at we need
to wait way these views carefully and
determine whether current law is
sufficient under these circumstances or
needs improvement let me say in
conclusion that I have communicated with
the Chairman my concerns that we follow
procedures that will allow us to get the
facts we need in a manner that minimizes
the attendant risk of prejudice and
adverse publicity it has been widely
reported that the witness at today's
hearing is under investigation by the US
attorney in the SEC we've known that mr.
Milken intends to assert his
constitutional rights and that he will
decline to answer any questions for
these reasons I don't believe that a
hearing today furthers the investigation
of the subcommittee and I don't believe
it has been fair to call this witness
under these circumstances I have been
assured by the Chairman how of them that
these hearings will be conducted in a
fair manner and I trust that this course
will be followed Thank You mr. chairman
Gerry thank you gentlemen for their
further opening statements
the true gentleman from Tuscany
gentleman from New York Dumbo's
recognized mr. chairman this
subcommittee has engaged in an important
investigation of the nation's securities
markets this investigation has focused
on the high-yield bond Department of the
investment banking firm of Drexel
Burnham Lambert and has examined several
issues of debt securities these
issuances and subsequent trading
activities raised important legal and
policy questions that we should explore
carefully and dispassionately our
inquiries should be thorough and we
should not jump to any conclusions until
our investigation is completed the
Subcommittee on Oversight and
investigations has the right and the
duty to examine the securities markets
to determine whether they operate in the
best interest of investors the economy
and the public we also may inquire
whether the securities laws should be
strengthened to outlaw practices that
are legal but are nefarious destructive
and unethical we cannot decide whether
new laws are needed until we have a
thorough investigation a thorough
understanding of current industry
practices our witness today is a man who
is under investigation and scrutiny by
the federal government has been widely
reported in the press that Michael
Millikin has been the subject of
investigations by the SEC in the US
Attorney and therefore while mr.
Milliken may be eminently qualified to
help our subcommittee because of his
expertise in and knowledge of the
workings of the junk bond industry
everyone here today fully expects that
he will assert his constitutional rights
and declined to answer this
subcommittee's questions and certain
questions mr. Chairman I intend to
protect propound relative to drechsel's
activities as financial adviser and
investment banker for a home shopping
network of st. Petersburg Florida I am
committed to participating in this
subcommittee's efforts to uncover
securities fraud and detect abuses in
the securities markets I received
assurances that the transactions we are
examining in connection with this
inquiry did not in any way relate to
other investigations being undertaken by
other federal authorities and I am
therefore hopeful that we mil will make
progress today in furthering our
investigation
Thank You mr. Jim chair thanks of
gentleman gentleman from Florida is
recognized mr. chairman I'm pleased that
you have called this hearing to explore
the trading activities of high-yield
securities by drexel burnham it's
important that as elected
representatives we strive to always be
on the lookout to ensure that there
aren't any market manipulations or
abuses in securities transactions I'm
especially interested in a series of
hearings since there are thousands of
investors in my congressional district
who have faith in our capitalistic
system I want to make sure they're
protected from devious schemes that seek
to defraud them or deny them the
opportunity to make a maximum return on
their investments my interests also
stems from the fact that there is a
company in my district which is a major
employer this company has recently filed
suit in the US District Court alleging
that direct so on a so called Chuck
bought Network manipulated its stock
downward many of my constituents are
investors in this company the stock of
this company reached a high of 47
dollars early last year and is now
around $5 you must admit this is a
pretty dramatic drop one which is a more
concern to me when one considers that
most of my constituents are senior
citizens on fixed incomes
needless to say I'm most anxious to see
how the high-yield bond market works and
how a firm performs its roles both
underwriter and market maker I look
forward to the testimony we will receive
today and tomorrow Thank You mr.
chairman
the Milken of the chair welcomes you to
the committee and we thank you for your
presence today the chair has several
qualifying matters to address before you
are recognized
first the chair advises you that copies
of the rules of the committee the rules
of the subcommittee are there in the red
and the beige books which are before you
those are there to advise you of both
your rights as you appear before the
committee and also the limitations upon
the power of the committee to conduct
its enquiries today the chair asks if
you have any objection to appearing
under oath at this time the chair then
inquires if you desire to be represented
by counsel yes mr. Chairman I assume
that mr. Williams who sits there to your
left is your choice of counsel is that
correct yes mr. chairman you've made an
excellent choice of counsel of the chair
will observe that mr. Williams was my
criminal law craft the prof Beck in
Georgetown University Law School a
number of years ago I hope he remembers
me with the same affection respect and
kindness that I do him from our
associations those days if you have no
objection then to being sworn mr. Milken
will you please rise and raise your
right hand
so help you God yes there's nothing you
may consider yourself to be under oath
mr. chairman before the interrogation
begins please sir may we respectfully
invoke rule 11 3 2 regarding television
radio and live photography the
provisions to which you elude mr.
Williams are would you would you would
you want to state them so the chair has
clearly before has the reasons for it
rather the rule and the reasons for it
rule 11 plus 3 F 2 of the rules of the
House of Representative provide no
witness served with a subpoena by the
committee shall be required against his
or her will to be photographed at any
hearing or to give evidence or testimony
well at the broadcasting of that hearing
by radio or television is being
conducted at the request of any such
witness who does not wish to be
subjected to radio television or still
photography coverage all lenses shall be
covered in all microphones used for
coverage turned off mr. Williams the
chair observes that you have asserted on
behalf of your client an absolute right
under the house rules the chair
instructs that all to all television
cameras and all microphones shall be
shut off at this particular time and the
lenses shall be kept and and or the
cameras will be faced towards the wall
so at this particular time the chair
instructs our guests who are appearing
here with television cameras microphones
devices of this of that kind that they
shall be turned off kept on the lenses
or face towards the wall of the
committee so that your rights mr. Milken
are fully protected under the rules of
the house following the hearing the
subcommittee chairman and others
discussed this morning's proceedings